if you want to know how Courtney
Whitmore went from relative obscurity to
having her own TV show and how she's
carrying on a tradition of heroism that
stretches back a solid 80 years keep
watching to learn the real truth behind
DC's star girl Courtney Whitmore carries
on a legacy that goes all the way back
to the 1940s before she was star girl
Courtney was the star-spangled kid that
identity once belonged to Sylvester
Pemberton who made his debut in the
pages of 1941 star-spangled comics
number one he and his sidekick stripe
see Stars and Stripes get it were a
patriotic take on Batman and Robin a
fabulously wealthy crime fighter and his
sidekick
they had no superpowers just a talent
for hand-to-hand combat and a cool car
the twist was that the kid was the hero
and the grown-up was the sidekick
Sylvester was the teenage heir to the
Pemberton family fortune and Stripes
seat was Pat Dugan his chauffeur the duo
started going through some rough times
before the end of the decade they were
eventually shoved out of their own book
by a character who was introduced to be
their sidekick marry the girl of 1,000
gimmicks stripes he would fall by the
wayside as the years went on but
Sylvester would have a much more tragic
end for characters who had their origins
tied to World War 2 it became
increasingly difficult to explain why
they hadn't aged over time Captain
America for example had to be a man out
of time
frozen in a block of ice for however
long it's been since the war the
star-spangled kid stripes he and the
other members of their super team the
seven soldiers of victory all got caught
in a time warp back in 1948 when they
emerged in the future Sylvester took the
name sky man and began using a cosmic
converter belt that gave him superpowers
he teamed up with the children of some
characters from his era to form a group
called infinity Inc in infinity Inc
number 51 a villain called the Harlequin
not the one you're thinking of and
Solomon Grundy crashed a wedding
literally in the ensuing fight Grundy
grabs a hero called mr. bones and shoves
bones his hand against sky man's face
among bones his superpowers with cyanide
touch that killed instantly leaving a
distinct burn on his Vic
so Pemberton got his face burned off and
while that's probably the most medal way
to die it's also a sad end for an
obscure hero in the 90s there was a
trend at DC Comics of dusting off long
forgotten heroes and breathing new life
into them and star man by James Robinson
Tony Harris and Peterson a Berg was a
highlight of the decade the name star
man had been used several times at DC
over the years starting with Golden Age
hero Ted Knight who used a cosmic rod to
fly through the air and zap bad guys
1994 star man picks up with his son
David who carries on his family's
tradition of heroism for roughly 45
minutes before being shot and killed on
his first night as a superhero
the legacy then falls to Ted's other son
Jack a sullen hipster who at least at
first has absolutely no interest in
becoming a superhero the series unifies
all the different starmon
including two different alien princes a
teenager from the 31st century and some
dude from the 80s that nobody liked into
the same legacy and jack upgraded the
flashlight sized cosmic rod to a
five-foot cosmic staff eventually he
finds himself raising his own son which
leads him to retire from the superhero
business he also meets a young woman
named Courtney Whitmore who had no
relation to the knight family or its
legacy not yet anyway remember Pat Dugan
the bumbling but ridiculously strong
grown-up sidekick stripesy well it
turned out that in the years since he'd
returned from being lost in time with
the other soldiers of victory he retired
from super heroics and settled down with
a woman named Barbara Whitmore that's
the basis of stars and stripe a 1999
revival of the star-spangled kid by
Geoff Johns and Lee motor when Dukan
stepdaughter courtney discovers the
relics of a superhero past she steals
the cosmic converter belt and goes into
action as the all-new star-spangled kid
initially motivated purely by teenage
rebellion to keep tabs on her Pat
deploys a secret project a massive suit
of robotic power armor called the
special tactics robotic integrated power
enhancer or stripe with that the classic
duo was reunited in a brand new
though the series sadly only lasted 14
issues before being cancelled it would
have been easy for Courtney Whitmore to
fade into obscurity after the end of her
series but she managed to stick around
like most throw backs to the golden age
she wound up joining the Justice Society
of America for a while serving is one of
the few younger members tasked with
hanging out with crime-fighting senior
citizens while she was with the Justice
Society Courtney got caught up in the
sins of youth crossover that ran in
young justice
the basic idea was that heroes swapped
ages with their sidekicks so the Justice
Society as the oldest heroes became a
pack of troublemaking toddlers while
Cortney herself was aged up into an
adult star woman who had to keep track
of them all during that time she made
use of Jack Knights cosmic staff in the
final issue of star men Jack Knight tied
up all the loose plot threads that had
been running through his book for the
past seven years including passing on
his own legacy to the next generation of
heroes Jack and Courtney had never
really gotten along given that their
teenage rebellions took them in opposite
directions but the glimpse II got of
Courtney and sins of youth made him
realize that she was the person who
should be carrying his legacy forward so
when Courtney returned to her correct
age she left the identity of the
star-spangled kid behind taking up
Jack's cosmic staff as star girl when
she was part of the Justice Society
Courtney met and began a romantic
relationship with one of the most
notable icons of the Golden Age Billy
Batson once called Captain Marvel but
better known these days as Shazam you
ask me
flight with visibility I thought that
was stupid but no one looked like this
the issue here was that Courtney was 16
years old were the readers that's not
actually a big deal at all
we all know that Billy is also a
teenager and that it's just the magic
word in the thunderous boom of lightning
that gives him the body of an adult when
it's time to do magical superhero stuff
but the rest of the Justice Society was
completely unaware of this fact
Courtney herself only found out when
they were on a mission together that saw
Billy briefly lose his powers so did
their teammates it seemed a grown man
with Superman powers was dating in under
each girl jay garrick the original flash
confronted Shazam about the relationship
in JSA number 59 rather than just
telling grandpa flash what the deal was
Billy decided that it was better to
destroy his reputation and just quit the
JSA to keep his identity a secret from
some of the most trustworthy heroes of a
time he also broke it off with Courtney
explaining that while he truly cared
about her he didn't want to run the risk
of having the team treat him poorly
because he was a teenager he wasn't
exactly using the wisdom of Solomon
right then it seems for a relatively
obscure cult favorite character Courtney
Whitmore has made a surprising number of
appearances in the world outside of
comics that may just have something to
do with how Geoff Johns went from
writing the short-lived stars and stripe
comic to serving his chief creative
officer of DC Entertainment from 2010 to
2018 where he took a very active role in
shaping the film and television side of
things both Courtney and Pat Dugan
showed up on Justice League Unlimited
alongside the other modern incarnations
of the seven soldiers of victory for the
record I don't have powers potty mouth
it's the staff as a solo act star Girl
has made appearances on multiple
animated series she was briefly seen on
Batman The Brave and the bold and more
recently she's been featured on Justice
League action and Young Justice
Outsiders although she's not a superhero
in that last one instead she's the host
of a celebrity focused TV show called
star girl in live action star girl
played a big role in Smallville's
two-part absolute justice event which
dove into the history of the Justice
Society and the idea of Clark Kent
carrying on a heroic legacy that dated
back to 1940 in that world Courtney took
the identity of star girl after
Sylvester Pemberton was killed with the
idea that he'd been part of a team of
heroes who were branded as criminals as
part of a government conspiracy in a
truly wild departure from her comics
history star girls showed up on legends
of tomorrow we're like on Smallville she
was tied to the Justice Society but on
legends she wasn't a legacy character
instead she was a founding member back
in World War two essentially replacing
both Sylvester Pemberton
Ted Knight in the arrow vs version of
that era here's where things start to
get weird
even by superhero standards first we
have to talk about the spear of destiny
which is supposedly the spear that a
Roman soldier named Longinus used to
stab Jesus during the crucifixion
understandably it's become a legendary
artifact with powers and superhero
stories for example in DC continuity
Hitler's possession of the spear gave
him the ability to mind-control anyone
with powers explaining why the
superheroes didn't just go win world war
ii before all the bad stuff happened on
legends of tomorrow the spear was so
powerful that the heroes broke it into
four pieces and scattered it throughout
the timestream star girl wound up taking
a fragment of it back to the 6th century
where she landed in britain hit her
piece of the spear inside a sword that
was itself inside a stone and then
helped King Arthur found Camelot after
taking the name Merlin Merlin
Justin identity I adopted to fit into
this era though the legends offered her
a ride home she ended up staying in the
past because she'd fallen in love with
Arthur going back to Camelot and
becoming a mythical wizard is certainly
a long way from her adventures as a high
school hero in 2020 Courtenay is set to
finally get another shot as a starring
role but not in comics instead she'll be
featured in star girl a live-action show
in the DC Universe streaming service
with episodes also airing on the CW
after they premiere it's not to be
confused with a Disney plus series
curiously of the same name produced by
Geoff Johns who's also writing the pilot
the show seems to be sticking a little
closer to the original comic than the
one where star girl goes back in time to
become Merlin this time Courtney
Whitmore played by Breck Basinger is a
high school student who discovers that
her stepfather used to be a sidekick
and she decides to raid his stash of
equipment to take up the family business
for herself in addition to Courtney and
Pat Dugan played by Luke Wilson the show
is also set to include a handful of
members of the Justice Society including
Wildcat our man and dr. midnight with
community star Joel McHale as sylvester
pemberton the one big difference is that
the show looks like it's skipping
over the star-spangled kid identity with
Pemberton having been Starman back in
the day instead whether it'll pick up on
other members of star girls supporting
cast from that original comic like her
high school rival Cindy Berman who
became a super villain named Shiv and
gave Courtney the closest thing she ever
had to an arch enemy remains to be seen
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Lube or videos about
superhero TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you